alors on vienne l'entendre pour belgrade
si la question du kosovo est sacrée
c'est que ce territoire est considéré
comme le berceau de la nation
les serbes ont perdu une bataille il ya
très longtemps mais cette défaite est
entré véritablement dans la mythologie
et c'est ce que nous montrent maintenant
régis nussbaum le kosovo une région
pauvre et montagneuse partagé entre
serbes et albanais depuis le moyen-âge
historiquement ces onze mille kilomètres
carrés de terres étaient habités par les
villes rien ancêtres des albanais
présent également en albanie et dans une
partie de la macédoine et du monténégro
le premier tournant a lieu en 11 181
avec l'arrivée des slaves en deux
siècles ils construisent des villes et
des monastères leur empire dure jusqu'en
13 180 date de la bataille dite du champ
des merles bataille sanglante qui scelle
la victoire des ottomans sur les princes
serbe
c'est le deuxième tournant pendant cinq
siècles le kosovo va rester sous
domination turque
une partie des serbes fui les albanais
se convertissent à l'islam
le troisième tournant intervient en 1912
durant les guerres balkaniques
les serbes reprennent le kosovo une
reconquête consacré par leur victoire
aux côtés les alliés après la première
guerre mondiale
la province est désormais le symbole du
nationalisme serbe
vingt ans plus tard
quito prend le pouvoir en yougoslavie en
1974 il accorde une large autonomie au
kosovo tito meurt en 1981 un an plus
tard les albanais du kosovo se soulèvent
pour demander une république
indépendante au sein de la yougoslavie
mais l'époque n'est plus aux concessions
slobodan milosevic est devenu l'homme
fort de la serbie
et en 1989 il abolit l'autonomie du
kosovo la yougoslavie n'a plus que
quelques mois d'existence avant son
éclatement